man they were giving out these cool
glasses at the screening these
sunglass looking things i was like oh
perfect for a thumbnail i forgot them at
the movie theater they're in the cup
holder
right now they're probably in the trash
now anyhow now i got to have some
generic ass thumbnail that looks like me
doing this or something like that
i can't win them all all right let's
review the sequel to the greatest movie
of 2016.
[Music]
so thus suicide squad is the sequel to
suicide squad this time this is written
and directed by james gunn in this movie
it's kind of treated like a mulligan for
suicide squad but it still treats the
universe like
well it still happened which works out
for this movie because the original
suicide squad movie
did the heavy lifting in terms of what
the suicide squad
is why amanda waller has it how they get
these people to go on these missions so
all this movie has to do is be like yeah
we'll take time off your sentence all
right sweet go
go forth for king and country still
recognizes that the first movie happened
in the sense that it doesn't waste my
time i appreciate that so now you have
these new characters that make up the
suicide squad for the most part and they
have a new mission to go to
and complete which is code four there's
no jared leto's joker in this movie
there's no sky beam at the end of the
movie and there's none of this so
you know
if you're gonna start off on a new foot
but there's a lot more that this movie
did that worked
better than how it was executed in the
first movie first of all the characters
had better contrast between them
and better synergy they worked off of
each other better you have john cena's
character and idris elba's character
they work well off of each other they're
both trying to
alpha dog each other as they would do
they're shooting people but they're just
mean mugging each other it's like
legolas and gimli but much less friendly
like sylvester stallone as the shark
character
he has no friends then you have this
lady i call the rat queen like
look we're getting into the deep sweaty
we're getting into the deep cuts
of these obscure comic book characters i
don't know them as well like in first
suicide squad
i actually knew the characters i'm like
oh i know who killer croc is i know who
deadshot is i know who rick flagg is i
generally know who these characters are
i don't know who polka dot guy and rat
queen are i just don't but in a world
where ninja turtles and batman have
crossed over before in my own head
cannon she is the daughter of the rat
king
and that is that but point is she is the
heart and soul
of this movie she's just a really sweet
person she's very endearing you're just
like
you're so nice how did you get wrapped
up with all of them
in all of this she's a very tragic and
lovable character so a friendly
character who befriends rats and a shark
with no friends
they worked well together too and the
polka dot there's a man who shoots polka
dots that's his power
in my head cannon also he is the same
character from the dark knight but how
dumb does that sound
saying it out loud dude shoots polka
dots that's his superpower like right
there you're like this is
they're scraping the bottom of the
barrel but it really is advantageous
for this movie and the premise they have
a freedom to do whatever they want with
these characters like they won't have
that freedom with
batman or someone high profile also
cherry on top if you can take an obscure
character with a weird power like that
and make them awesome and make their
power badass they make the characters
indispensable to the team both
personally
and with their powers you know there's
one moment in this movie that stands out
to me with harley quinn is that's the
fact that
she is crazy you know like harley
quinn's been an anti-hero for long
enough you know and
she's working with the good guys a lot
and you forget that she's
actually insane there's a scene in here
where she does a thing and
i mean it's not a bad thing i shed no
tears but the way it was executed i was
like
oh yeah you're not saying and she has
one of my favorite scenes in the movie
like
actually my favorite scene bar none in
this movie
a scene with harley quinn and it's she's
completely badass it's like a thing that
birds of prey tried to do and the
suicide squad
did idris elba was great in the movie i
always say like idris elba's one of
those actors where
even if he's in a movie which the
suicide squad
isn't a movie but even when he is
in a movie
he's still great in the movie he's
one of those actors man where he's
like yeah i mean i'll crush it on my
part that doesn't mean the movie's good
also another standout that's in the
first suicide squad movie
is also in this movie um amanda waller
viola davis as amanda waller
perfect casting was then is now she's
just such a dick
and she's so good at it i don't know how
she does it it's just i don't know how
people are like that in real life
i don't know how they're that good at it
in movies
but she's so good at being amanda waller
also yeah the movie's really bloody
it's violent it's rated r it uses that
absolutely
actually uses that with some of the
humor too i mean violence and humor is
just
we all love it i mean if you don't i
don't know maybe i'm projecting i do i
don't know some stylish violence that
reminds me of mortal kombat fatalities
i just that speaks to me and visual
effects in this movie were really good
surprisingly shockingly good i don't
know why i didn't expect that i didn't
expect to look at the shark and be like
this is actually really good lighting on
his skin it's
props and it being written and directed
by james gunn you know he's going for
more of a comedy than the original
suicide squad was and yeah that's an
expectation that
that is what the movie is like i already
said some of it's tied in with the gore
some of it's just
really odd that is to say some of it
really landed with me some of it just
didn't i was like oh okay that was
that happened it doesn't change the fact
that there were quite a few moments in
this movie that i found hilarious
and they absolutely do outweigh the
moments that were just kind of amiss for
me but guys in the end the suicide squad
great bloody fun it does away with that
vibe that feels like you just
snorted a can of surge energy drink it
gives you more of a
bloody gory comic book action comedy so
what's the writing for the suicide squad
i'll give you a hint
no no it's not a good time if you're
drunk this is for me survive in my
comment section to see that paradigm
shift of those comments going from
remember this guy gave suicide squad to
buy it on blu-ray rating two remember
this is the guy who gave suicide squad
and the suicide squad the same rating
that is to say the suicide squad is
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray
[Music]
here we go in my defense i did try to
fix the timeline of my deadpool 2
spoiler talk video so
couldn't do it all right so the suicide
squad have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more
click right here to see more
you